[Music]
guys let's face it it's pretty rare when
your teammate says don't worry I got
this and doesn't proceed to throw the
entire match afterwards but sometimes
when you throw caution to the wind when
the impossible is made possible the
results can be legendary they're all
together
PPD he comes the ice blocks ready
[Music]
sometimes you just have to throw the
rulebook out the window and remember
what Drake said once upon a time you
only live once so from Aegis snatches to
noscopes to base races some of the best
plays in competitive gaming history have
been made by a guy who says bucket I'm
going in here are the top ten Yolo plays
in eSports kicking off our list is
reiha's back worthy son strike on mid
one doing the group stage of the
International 2018 after successfully
harassing the enemy drow Ranger out of
Lane we keeps a close watch on her path
thing as she walks back to base men one
knows this of course and paths
unpredictably as a result rates ban no
boots billed for mid wand look at this
mid one it he knows that the substract
might come strike is up he's watching we
but just as drow appears to have safely
made her way back to base whee-ha throws
out a Hail Mary for the ages
that's my boy
coming in at number nine is Pines
infamous wrap around on junker town from
the overwatch league's inaugural season
the sneaky flank that pine sets up not
only ensures that he has the element of
surprise over his enemies but mostly
guarantees that he'll throw the hold
entirely if this manoeuvre doesn't work
out but when the big boss can it looks
like this failure is rarely on the cards
formation as you're about to see with
the infra site and nailed the shots not
many widow-makers would go for this play
[Applause]
the number 8 play on our list is an
iconic play from one of cs gos greatest
that's right we're talking about simples
notorious clutch against Team Liquid at
ESL one New York 2016 down into a
one-on-one good trades but it's simple
and he's already finding himself in a
post planet one be 1 against nitro
simple is forced into a risky retake
with an OP but knowing that nitros got
the jump on him the Ukrainian phenom
tosses out the most unexpected audacious
and expensive of distractions smoke
could be really rough for simple tanks
to get through this he's got
[Music]
[Applause]
if it is that just you come that is just
Eiling on nitro that's it just mentally
breaking him saying I'm just going to
utterly dominate you in this one-on-one
you don't even deserve to be in the same
server as be coming in at number seven
is fakers crisp shockwave against Edward
gaming during world's 2017 s group stage
up nine kills in a hefty 10,000 gold EDG
had SKT on the ropes but SKT right now
they're looking into sarchie top spot
that is it's almost impossible threat to
come back but instead of clawing at
their lead by playing defensively SKT
decided to turn things up a notch with
an aggressive rotation and after
spotting EDG x' attempt to barrel down
mid faker decided that now was the
perfect time to land a face-melting
shockwave
door shock wave and SKT
did it they pulled back from
dull deficit I wanted to fight against
all expectations
because in half a second every
coming in at number six is the hottest
plan our list courtesy of the legendary
olofmeister into science finds it makes
no finding himself in a perilous post
plant situation at ESL one cologne 2014
well I've had no choice but to brave the
flames of devices incendiary grenade to
pull off this ninja defuse small
counter-strike matches and that was a
millisecond away from being the
difference between defuse or death
whereas most people would have quickly
retreated Olaf says [ __ ] it and sticks
it out to win the round with a meager 5
health remaining
[Music]
at the midway point on our list is that
time that Kenny s brought a knife to a
gunfight at ESL one cologne 2015 locked
in an intense one be one against
Guardian these two legendary offers
danced around each other on infernos a
site with Guardian whiffing his noscopes
and Kenny unable to land his pistol
shots the Frenchman had no choice but
the clutches blade say a prayer and take
to the skies
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh I didn't Lord that was putting all
that if any have picking up so many
kills in that round our list just
wouldn't be complete without a healthy
dose of eternal Envy and his solo bass
race against LGD at the 2015 dota 2 Asia
Championships comes in at number four on
our list with LGD pushing the high
ground in cloud nine unable to put up an
appropriate defense and be made the
risky decision to TP bottom for an
all-in split push quickly running out of
options
although NV here you go into the back
door is real he gives the mid lane of
barracks this could turn into another
good old-fashioned bay frame with the
help of his manta illusions and the
armor reducing desolator he buys from
the enemy fountain NV tries to beat out
the entirety of LGD in a no-holds-barred
base race for the ages he's doing what
damage he can trade yet they still have
to clip that stop de deadness crash but
they can't focus and throw themselves
instead they have to deal with the
heroes Botha doing a lot of damage this
is gonna be damn close so much on the
line here internal enemy might be able
to do it to get his teammate place LGD
they just let the throw but they can't
attend me oh my god winter you called it
and NV did it making his second
appearance on our list of Yolo plays is
simple this time for his iconic
jaw-dropping clutch against fnatic at
ESL one cologne 2016 finding himself on
the losing end of a 1v2 against fnatic
simple decides to drop from heaven with
his op and rack up not one but two no
scopes
while the first kill is pretty
mind-blowing the second is just
downright impossible
it literally shouldn't have happened and
is even better with the Russian casters
taking the penultimate spawn on our list
is none other than expectation thymus
backdoor against SK gaming at IEM
katowice 2013 with alarmingly little
health and a teleport to boot expec a
spots an opportunity to close at the
match and put this tense bloodbath to
rest using cassadines mobility and a
shitload of concentration Pekka is able
to deke out his opponents and take down
the enemy Nexus until he'd stolen not
only the match but every last shred of
eske's dignity
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
taking the top spot on our list is off
ooh and is all too famous thief in the
night maneuver against virtus Pro during
TI sevens upper bracket it's important
to note that virtus Pro aren't desperate
to slay Roshan since they need the ages
to close out this nail-biter of a match
against LGD forever you lfy being two
racks down against him and it looks like
for the Marmot rolling ball to offer
[Music]
for what really makes this our top Yolo
play is the fact that you can't ward
inside the Rosh pit and the only way to
see inside of it is to have a unit in
there that's right you just watched a
man dive into the Rosh pit blind and do
the impossible guys that right there is
what eSports is all about so for more
goosebump inducing content from
biographies to listicles like this one
don't forget to sub to the channel like
this video and comment below on what you
want to see us do next and I'll see you
next time thanks for watching if you
want more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages